entropy can be measured on an absolute
scale which means there is a point of
zero entropy
and that point is reached for a pure
crystalline substance when the
temperature is equal to zero kelvin or
absolute zero at zero kelvin the entropy
of the pure crystalline substance s is
equal to zero
we can think about why the entropy is
equal to zero by looking at the equation
developed by boltzmann that relates
entropy s to number of microstates w a
microstate refers to a microscopic
arrangement of all of the positions and
energies of all of the particles for our
pure crystalline substance at absolute
zero all of the particles are perfectly
ordered in their lattice states
and at 0 kelvin there's no thermal
motion so all of the particles are
perfectly ordered in their lattice
states with no thermal motion that means
there's only one possible arrangement
for these particles and that means
there's only one microstate
so when we think about our equation if
we plug in the number of microstates is
equal to one the natural log of one is
equal to zero which means that the
entropy is equal to 0 at 0 kelvin for
this pure crystalline substance this is
called the third law of thermodynamics
next let's think about what happens to
our hypothetically perfect crystal if we
increase the temperature the increased
temperature means the particles gain
energy and have motion around their
lattice states therefore there's an
increase in the number of possible
microstates and if there's an increase
in the number of microstates according
to the equation developed by boltzmann
that also means an increase in entropy
since we started with zero entropy at
zero kelvin and the entropy increases at
all temperatures that are greater than
zero kelvin the entropy must be greater
than zero or you could say the entropy
is positive we can get the units for
entropy from the boltzmann constant k k
is equal to 1.38 times 10 to the
negative 23rd joules per kelvin so we'll
use these units for entropy
now that we understand the concept of
zero entropy let's look at the entropy
of a substance and let's say that we
have one mole of carbon in the form of
graphite
standard entropy refers to the absolute
entropy of a substance at a pressure of
one atmosphere and a specified
temperature often that temperature is 25
degrees celsius
the standard entropy of graphite at 25
degrees celsius is equal to 5.7 joules
per kelvin and since we're dealing with
one mole of graphite we could write the
units as joules per kelvin mole and
often this is called standard molar
entropy the standard molar entropy of
graphite is positive because it's being
compared to a hypothetically perfect
crystal of graphite at 0 kelvin so
really it's a change in entropy and
therefore it would be 5.7 minus 0 with 0
being the entropy of a hypothetical
crystal at 0 kelvin however when we
write standard molar entropies we don't
include the delta sign and we reserve
the delta sign for processes such as
phase changes or also chemical reactions
the superscript knot refers to the
standard state of the substance by
convention the standard state of a solid
or liquid is referring to the pure solid
or pure liquid under a pressure of 1
atmosphere for gases standard state is
referring to the pure gas at a pressure
of one atmosphere
and for solutions we're talking about a
solution with a concentration of one
molar in our case we're talking about
one mole of carbon in the form of
graphite in the solid state therefore
the standard molar entropy of graphite
is referring to the entropy value for 1
mole of a pure solid under a pressure of
1 atmosphere
next let's look at a table showing
standard molar entropies of different
substances at 25 degrees celsius we just
saw that the standard molar entropy of
carbon in the form of graphite is equal
to 5.7 joules per kelvin mole let's
compare that solid to two other standard
molar entropies for example liquid water
has a standard molar entropy of 69.9
and methane gas has a standard molar
entropy of 186.3
looking at these numbers in general
gases have higher standard molar
entropies than liquids as we can see
comparing the values and liquids in
general have higher standard molar
entropies than solids the reason why
this is generally true has to do with
the number of microstates available to
solids liquids and gases
solids are held together by either
chemical bonds or by intermolecular
forces liquids are held together by
intermolecular forces and gases if we
assume ideal gases there are no
intermolecular forces between the
particles
so in general as we go from a solid to a
liquid to a gas there's an increase in
the number of possible arrangements of
particles there's an increased freedom
of movement and therefore going from
solid to liquid to gas means an increase
in the number of possible microstates
and an increase in the number of
possible microstates means an increase
in entropy
next let's compare the standard molar
entropies of two gases methane is 186.3
whereas ethane is 229.6
looking at their dot structures methane
is on the left and ethane is on the
right they're both composed of carbon
and hydrogen however ethane has more
carbons and more hydrogens single bonds
allow free rotation and since ethane has
more bonds than methane there's more
ways for the ethane molecule to rotate
bonds can also stretch and compress like
a spring so we could imagine this
carbon-carbon bond having some
vibrational motion and since ethane has
more bonds than methane ethane has more
ways to vibrate than methane does more
ways to rotate and more ways to vibrate
mean that there are more possible ways
to distribute the energy in ethane than
in methane and an increased number of
ways of distributing energy means an
increase in the number of available
microstates which means an increase in
the entropy so in general as there's an
increase in the number of atoms or an
increase in the molar mass from say
methane to ethane there's also an
increase in entropy
next let's calculate the standard change
in entropy for a chemical reaction for
our reaction let's look at the
decomposition of one mole of calcium
carbonate turning into one mole of
calcium oxide and one mole of carbon
dioxide gas to calculate the standard
change in entropy for this chemical
reaction we need to sum up the standard
molar entropies of the products and from
that we subtract the sum of the standard
molar entropies of the reactants so
first we think about our products which
are calcium oxide and carbon dioxide so
we need to sum the standard molar
entropies of these two substances
next we think about our reactants and
for this reaction we have only calcium
carbonate so therefore we're going to
plug in the standard molar entropy of
calcium carbonate before we plug in our
values for standard molar entropies
let's predict the sign for the standard
entropy change for this reaction in our
reaction we go from one mole of a solid
to one mole of another solid and one
mole of a gas
we already know that in general gases
have higher values for entropy than
solids and since we have zero moles of
gas on the reactant side and one mole of
gas on the product side we would predict
that the sum of the standard molar
entropies of the products would be
greater than the sum of the standard
molar entropy of the reactants in this
case only one reactant and since we'd be
subtracting a smaller number from a
larger number we would predict that the
standard change in entropy for this
reaction
would be
positive
now that we've made our prediction let's
plug in our standard molar entropies and
these are for 25 degrees celsius and see
if our prediction was correct the
standard molar entropy of calcium oxide
is equal to 39.8 joules per kelvin mole
and in our balanced equation we have one
mole of calcium oxide so we're going to
multiply one mole of calcium oxide by
the standard molar entropy and moles
will cancel
next we look up the standard molar
entropy of carbon dioxide which is equal
to
213.6 joules per kelvin mole and our
balanced equation once again there's a
one in front of carbon dioxide so we're
going to multiply the standard molar
entropy by one mole and moles will
cancel so we're going to add those two
together and from that we're going to
subtract the standard molar entropy of
our reactant which is calcium carbonate
so the standard molar entropy of calcium
carbonate is 92.9 joules per kelvin mole
and in our balanced equation there's a 1
as a coefficient in front of calcium
carbonate so multiply that by one mole
and once again the moles will cancel out
for this particular reaction and the
balanced equation all the coefficients
happen to be one however if one of our
reactants or products in a different
reaction happen to have a coefficient of
2 we would multiply the standard molar
entropy by 2 moles
after we do the math we find that the
standard change in entropy for this
reaction is equal to positive
160.5 joules per kelvin therefore one
mole of calcium carbonate decomposing to
form one mole of calcium oxide and one
mole of carbon dioxide involves an
increase in entropy just as we had
predicted earlier on sometimes you'll
see the units as joules per kelvin and
sometimes you might see joules per
kelvin mole of reaction
to understand how to get those units
let's just consider the standard molar
entropy of carbon dioxide and that value
is 213.6
joules per kelvin per one mole of carbon
dioxide and looking at the balanced
equation there's a one as a coefficient
in front of carbon dioxide therefore
there's one mole of carbon dioxide per
one mole of reaction so mole of reaction
is just talking about how the balanced
equation is written
so the one mole of carbon dioxide
cancels out
and that leaves us with joules per
kelvin mole of reaction
so using these units is simply saying
for the decomposition of one mole of
calcium carbonate there will be a change
in entropy of positive
160.5 joules per kelvin
therefore if we were talking about the
decomposition of two moles of calcium
carbonate the change in entropy would be
twice this value that we already
calculated